[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for an interview with an Emmy
nominee Jake schreier director on beef
congratulations very very well deserved
nomination right there thanks so much I
mean it you know how much I love the
show so you got nominated for
outstanding director uh for a limited or
Anthology series or movie but in
addition to that beef also wound up with
12 other nominations and this feels like
a little bit of an unfair question but
of all the other nominees for beef which
ones surprised and excited you the most
like one where when their name was
called you sat there and said to
yourself like yes I am so incredibly
thrilled that they got the recognition
they deserved oh you can't but don't
make me do this I I I think uh
I don't know I mean look I could also
talk about Larkin and Grace Super
nominated I think like when there's that
many nominations for a show like what
just feels really good is it feels like
the show connected with people and I
don't think that you know any one
specific nomination over another
again like I think you know I think we
just everyone that day like we wrote up
everyone who had worked on the show and
said thank you and you know how much I
learned
had been a part of it so I know that's
like highly diplomatic but but I do mean
it like there wasn't like one shock or
anything that that happened so it's
appropriate fair enough one of my
favorite nominations that was called was
your sound team because I believe they
were nominated for the same episode you
were and I just like to think in my mind
that their nomination was solely for a
certain death in that episode
beautifully crafted all right before I
jump into beef full force just to uh
have our viewers get to know you a
little more and also because you you've
had a bit of a unique journey in terms
of the types of things that you direct
and you know your next feature film I
believe is going to be your first
feature as director since like 2015. so
you direct uh Robot and Frank and Paper
Towns and then from there go on to
direct slew of music videos and then
after that a whole bunch of series
credits and now you're gonna make your
way back to Features with Thunderbolts
how much of that trajectory was
determined by what you were interested
in creatively on a personal level versus
going with the flow of a constantly
evolving industry I think yeah I think
probably mostly going with the flow I
mean obviously it's always determined by
what interests you and then but but the
flow changes you know
where that interest is going to come
from and what format it's going to be in
you know so I think yeah there was never
any plan that okay now it's time to do
TV here now it's time to go back to like
the superhero movie I think you know
it's just what comes in that feels like
it grabs you and expresses something
that you want to
work in or get better at or learn
something from and I think
you know that's the nice thing about all
of these parts I mean I also started in
commercials and I did music videos way
back when and that you know I think
there's almost never a project that you
don't learn something from you know and
I think
lately the thing I think a lot about is
just about fit and collaboration and who
you work with and just how lucky it is
like when you get
you know with something like beef you
know and I've been friends with sunny
for years but also with Larkin who shot
it and Grace production design that you
know these new friendships and old
friendships just what a great fit that
was and how much that fit contributes to
making something that feels unique and
special you know and it feels like a
thing to kind of take and think about
going forward in the in the business
along the way is there any particular
project that you gained more from than
you ever could have imagined where when
the opportunity came your way you might
have said like I don't know if now's the
right time for this but you opted to
commit and wound up getting more from it
than you ever could have anticipated
that's a good question uh I don't know
if it was something that I didn't want
to do I think like there was a time
when you know work wasn't coming as easy
where yeah I did start to focus on the
music videos a little bit more and music
videos with my friend
Francis whose band Edison Francis and
the lights and just getting to really
work on something even if it was in such
a small
bite-sized form that felt like you could
really
take it all the way from the beginning
to the end and keep it like a really a
sense of singular purpose
that felt like yeah that that was like
very fulfilling and rewarding in a time
where you don't always get that on some
of these other projects are where it
takes much longer to get there and I
think that led to kind of there was a
thing that we were exploring about like
really using long takes to capture a
moment in time and really see something
and also how to kind of work with other
like in the rest of the music videos
that I went on to make like tried to
kind of replicate that collaboration
with Francis where it feels very much
like his music video as much as
mine and trying to do that with other
artists somebody and them kind of
bring a lot of their own ideas like I
wouldn't I wouldn't just write
treatments and send them off like it
would have to be an artist that was
willing to talk to me about what they
wanted to see and then me try to
translate that somehow cinematically and
I think that ends up being valuable in
all kinds of ways especially like when
you're making something like beef or if
you like like episode three in the
church where you know I have no personal
connection to the Korean church but the
people who were there did you know and
really leaving the room
open for Stephen and for sunny and and
all of the people there to kind of bring
themselves to that scene and really make
something that feels personal and kind
of leaving the space for that that was
something that I picked up in music
videos that felt like an important
lesson to learn that's beautiful answer
I love hearing about how things build
along the way now jumping into beef full
force and starting with your Leads Here
of course uh Ali and Steven clearly the
two of them work together very well but
can you maybe tell us something unique
about each of their approaches to their
own work maybe even something that calls
for something different from you as an
actors director for both yeah I think
you know with Stephen
I mean he's just I don't know it's so
incredible he will not give you a false
moment but I think like you know for the
kind of writing that Sunny does and the
kind of direction that I do which is not
necessarily
entirely as observed like there's a
sense of purpose to it you know and
there's something that it's driving at
so there's a real value in having
something like Stephen who can hit all
of his Beats and it can be a very
technical actor and it can do action
very well
but then also gives you something that
is not at all what you expected out of
the moment you know like if I think
about an episode eight
when he's uh yelling at uh
at Edwin you know like what she did was
not nice it's not nice to do that you
know and like that was a line that I
loved in the script that Sonny wrote and
pictured an entirely different way and I
never really go in with like a
preconceived notion of it you have to do
the line this way or we're gonna run it
until this is what we get but either way
I just never pictured that but it was so
it's just surprising and great and I
think that like that combination is
something that is so special and really
like the height of what you can do is
when you can exist within a system of
filmmaking that is Technical and has
purpose but then you are still bringing
that level of reality and kind of
spontaneity to each of those moments and
we're you know each take might
functional on the same parameters and
hit these beats and hit these timings
but never actually be the same take or
be the same performance like that felt
really really
special with Stephen and then with Ali
yeah I think it was just
she just had this great level of
excitement about getting to do something
different than she had gotten to do up
until that point and maybe like came in
with one notion of what that would be
and then very quickly adjusted to
something entirely different and really
really made it
personal in this way to watch someone
kind of attack that with so much
kind of energy and excitement it was
just like really really beautiful to
watch and for her to keep hitting these
moments within some of those therapy
scenes
that you know like just really you're
like okay wow that was more than
anything that we had seen in rehearsal
and but just to see her kind of
Embrace that over the course of the
season was really really special and you
know for each of them you know I think I
mean Sunday's definitely talked about
this there's so much even before I
arrived that they had brought to the
series in just the conversations that
they had had the sunny in the
development phase of putting themselves
into these parts and pushing the
narrative forward so that by the time
you got there I mean not only
you know were they acting it well that
they really understood it on a level
that you didn't even have to discuss
necessarily with them because they had
already put those ideas into the
storyline and that's pretty special the
two of them are something else in this
and now I'm gonna follow that up with
yet another unfair question so I can
tease someone else in the Ensemble here
of all the other characters in beef
which one wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to direct than you ever could
have imagined day one
okay you're trying to make me pick
favorites and I won't do that I can't do
that uh I mean you know I think the
certainly I just want to be clear I'm
not saying this above anyone else of
course other nominees I mean I think
watching young you know there's
something very exciting when someone is
in one of their first Parts you know
like at least at the scale and to watch
Young
kind of grow into that and how kind of
real he was from the first moment but
also like develop an approach in an
acting stuff because they just haven't
gotten to do it that much before and be
that good night his first time out but
in one of those first times out I think
that that's really I think that's fun
for everyone to watch you know I think
that was something that just felt really
nice to see happen in front of your eyes
but everyone just brought so much of
themselves
I think all of it so like that was the
thing I noticed from the very first
table read was just how important that
show felt to the actors that were
involved and once you see something like
that it makes you want to really
you know be there for them and be at the
top of your game because you know how
important this is to everyone involved
and you don't want to be the one that
lets that down in any way that's a big
part of the reason why I ask a question
like that because you have a rather
large supporting uh Ensemble here and
it's not easy to make characters like
that feel full and real and like their
worlds are whole and lived in and every
single one of them manages to do it and
I think that's a big reason why you see
so many Emmy nominations for the show
and the acting categories I'll stick
with uh young for a minute more so
jumping into the the particular episode
you're nominated for it is episode nine
so everyone should know if you have not
caught up on beef do that but from this
point forward we will be talking about
spoilers I wanted to ask you about
directing him in one particular Scene It
is the conversation between Paul and
Danny in that walled off area can you
kind of walk us through the
conversations you two might have had in
terms of you know navigating Paul's
building reactions to all of the things
that Danny is confessing in particular
why he is so quick to brush off the
wiring error but then also making sure
that it's Justified when the the switch
flips in a way when he mentions the uh
the college application situation yeah I
think I I mean I wish that I could say
that there was some brilliant thing that
I told young to get into that place but
he just nailed it I mean he was just
there and you know something that was
nice about episode 9 is whereas most of
the show was shot entirely out of
sequence you know we cross-boarded it
like nine happened at the end nine and
ten happen kind of where they happened
within the storyline so there was like a
wealth of that relationship that had
been built up between him and Stephen at
that point and I think you know we sort
of
we did talk about how like there's an
amount of this that's understood between
these brothers about the dynamic and you
know a certain amount of rivalry or
wanting to keep each other down and he
understands a little bit about Danny and
what he's messed up but he doesn't but
something that deep
he maybe doesn't know and I think
there's also an element of it which you
know for
for Steven obviously you know he's
trying to reach this moment of honesty
in part to be selfless and push Paul
away from him to save Paul's life
and I think that
there's an element to which Paul even
might understand that in a way you know
even if even if there's a ton of anger
at that that there's a sense that
a break is made between the two of them
and that moment but but again I wish I
could say that you know I mean he was
just the two of them were just so there
and so ready for that moment when when
they played it that it mostly I just you
know you call Action you call cut and
you maybe say one thing and you watch
but yeah one incredible moment of many
in this particular episode so I'll ask
you a broader question now going into
filming episode nine which scene which
story did you think was going to be the
toughest to capture and then ultimately
was that indeed the hardest of the bunch
or did something else Catch You by
surprise I think I mean look there's
there's different kinds of heart right I
mean there's certainly just like a
resource question you know we knew that
we didn't have an actual massive SWAT
team outside and we didn't have you know
a ton of time to film the episode for
having a lot of action so there
certainly was an amount of nerves just
about being able to pull off the kind of
scope and the scale of it but I think
that moment you know and where Steven
got to with the you got to get away from
me man like you got to get away from me
like that lion was so beautiful in the
script that's not exactly how read like
Stephen brought that in that moment and
so when you're in the midst of this kind
of
you know chaotic melee and then you
still have actors finding moments that
real amidst it like that I think was the
biggest question that's like can we can
we pull off an episode like this that is
so heightened that hopefully we've built
two on a tonal level but can we still
find all of these really
beautiful character moments that Sunny
has been building up to in his writing
amidst that
and once I saw that and said it was like
okay yeah I think we can do it I think
we could get there very much did I'm I'm
gonna touch on one particular character
moment that you built towards especially
well and I want to know a little bit
about the conversations you had with
Ashley when shooting this particular
scene and of of course it's the button
pressing scene what do you two have to
talk through so that the intentions that
you want her to convey are clear if
there are any deliberate intentions
behind the timing of the pushing of the
button at all
right that was a big discussion about
like how what level of intent
button push and I I think that we landed
on we went back and forth
and I mean I think viewers can make of
it what what they will I mean certainly
she's been pushed to run on her own by
the fact that Jordan has been so cruel
and pushed her away so that break is
there between their two characters as
far as like I think it's a mixture
between
fear you know and a reaction and then
also maybe just a recognition that this
person does not have your best interest
that I heard him probably would not wait
for you if they were in the same
position but I don't think and we never
wanted it to be
some sort of void
cool diabolical turn that she makes to
turn on Jordan it's more just the break
has been made between those two
characters and in that moment that's
what it leads to you feel it when you're
watching it and I feel like you have
also like I'm a horror lover that is my
main number one genre I'll watch
anything that is my favorite you 100
delivered one of the best most memorable
on-screen deaths of 2023. hey
again it's all fit and team because it
you know the Way It Was Written she
didn't get
up it was just uh she got crushed in the
door and then it was like all right how
are we going to show that we probably
don't want to show too much of it you
know because it's better imagined as you
said and you know the incredible sound
design and then
we were talking about an American table
or DP that idea of these kind of we're
going back and forth on these reaction
close-ups which was what
was going to tell us that she was dying
was going to be on their reactions
and then he was just like you know you
could just have if the doors in the
foreground you could just have it close
and it was just you know it was just too
good an idea not to do like I think
everyone when they heard that it was
like okay yeah we gotta I don't care how
messed up that is we have to do it so
yeah messed up and so incredibly
effective I have to let you go in about
a moment so you know it is time for the
inevitable turn towards Marvel and
Thunderbolt I hope I can ask you some
safe questions here you can ask you can
ask the questions
cut off the internet connection yeah
really your high speed internet suddenly
is gone yeah exactly how that happened
yeah getting the opportunity to direct a
Marvel movie is a really big deal but I
am curious more about accepting it from
a personal perspective as a director
when you were offered the chance to
direct Thunderbolts what did you think
you would gain from that opportunity as
uh as a director evolving his craft I
think you know
what what jumped out was I mean first of
all the cast is just incredible and I
think like any movie with that cast like
how could you not be excited about
getting to work with that group of
people
um and then also you know John Watts was
my roommate from college and we're good
friends and so knowing this what a great
experience he had making those films
something that's certainly and I I even
did second you know like the LA portion
of one of the Spider-Man movies so like
adding a little bit more kind of
connection or insight into that world
um but beyond that it was just like a
really different approach and a new kind
of story to tell amidst that which I
know I've made so many things but it is
you know it's not a sequel um and it's
not you know yes these characters have
appeared before
but it is a news story being told in a
story I think with a very different
perspective than maybe people are
expecting and I think that that
felt exciting and felt like a real
challenge worth picking on with that in
mind and also some of the work I love
from you so much like like beef
obviously because we're talking about
that now but I'm also obsessed with
brand new cherry flavor that is a
phenomenal series when I think about
shows like that though I don't
necessarily watch them and say like that
guy's the right one to direct the next
Marvel movie which I actually do think
is a good thing and winds up exciting me
even more so I guess what can you tease
about the the tone the style and the
atmosphere of thunderbolts that will
indeed make it stand out and maybe tap
into some of those things we've seen you
uh do on screen before yeah I think in
the end it's I mean obviously I can say
so little but I think it's just about
it's about characters and is there
something specific to those characters
that bring them together and something
that they're going through that isn't
you know the most traditional superhero
you know story to be told and I think if
you can hit that and if you can make it
specific I think if you look at
something like beef what makes it what
it is is that it's
so specific on so many levels you know
Sunny brought so much of himself to it
Alex even everyone and in being that
specific becomes something Universal and
I think that's sort of similar to the
way that we're looking at Thunderbolts
is that there is a real
clear taken perspective on these
characters and there's a specificity to
it that in the end obviously we want to
make the big Universal movie that
everyone can connect to but that you can
only do that by making something that
feels personal and I think that's what's
exciting about the project to us I like
the sound of all that I'll dare to
squeeze in one more question because you
have you have the the unique qualities
that you are going to bring to the
franchise but of course it also has to
still feel like an MCU movie so of all
the past Marvel films maybe films that
you were watching or re-watching to prep
to actually direct Thunderbolts which
one did you find influencing or have
because it's still ongoing influencing
your approach to that film the most oh
man that's a tough
there's so many good ones I just this
isn't this is going to totally avoid
your question but just because it's he's
my good friend on this I'll just pick uh
I'll just pick a Spider-Man homecoming
just for just for John just so I don't
get in trouble with my friends how about
that I respect it's not gonna be like
our movie but but it is is very good and
I hope our movie is very good here's my
my one selfish pitch for you because
you're good friends with John and John's
working on another favorite franchise of
mine of
talk to him about looping you into the
ongoing Final Destination franchise
especially because Jordan's kill feels
like it's in that world
I had not but thank you for I had not I
had not made that kind of connection but
I am very excited about about what he's
making in that world in college that was
I remember
in the dorm room with him and Duncan and
Ford would all sit around watching Final
Destination all the time and talking
about the kill so I think fans will be
in very good hands with John's work on
that I've got very high hopes in him and
that team I must let you go but again
huge congratulations on the Emmy
nomination beef is hands down one of my
favorite series of the year and all
those nominations were very very well
deserved so congratulations and enjoy
something so much yeah yeah great to see
you again